tenemos aquí un ejercicio y dice donovan
come dos barras de granola y un vaso de
jugo de naranja como desayuno cada
mañana el precio de una barra de granola
es ve y el precio de un vaso de jugo de
naranja es j hay diferentes formas de
pensar cómo calcular el costo del
desayuno de donovan por siete días junto
a las expresiones con sus descripciones
correspondientes
entonces vamos a ver esas expresiones
que tenemos aquí y veamos con cuál de
estas descripciones corresponde
entonces dice aquí encontrar el costo
del desayuno de un día y multiplicarlo
por 7 qué quiere decir eso entonces el
costo del desayuno de un día y
multiplicarlo por 7 el cada día come 2
barras de granola y un jugo entonces
come dos veces y un jota dos barras de
granola y un jugo veamos dónde está esa
expresión entonces sería un jugo más dos
barras de granola y multiplicado por
siete esta descripción corresponde a esa
expresión acá dice encontrar el número
de vasos de jugo y barras de granola en
siete desayunos y sumar todos los
precios entonces esta expresión donde
está aquí encontrar el número de vasos
de jugo y barras de granola en siete
desayunos
y sumar todos los precios esto no puede
ser porque donovan come dos barras y un
jugo aquí está el revés aquí serían dos
jugos más una barra multiplicado por 7
que representa 7 días ahora veamos aquí
tenemos 7 jugos y 14 barras
esto tiene sentido porque en total el
tomara 7 jugos y como come 2 barras de
granola cada día 2 x 7 es 14 entonces 7
jugos más 14 barras esta es la
descripción que corresponde a esa
expresión y ninguna de las anteriores
bueno ya habíamos platicado que esta no
corresponde a ninguna de las dos
descripciones entonces esa es ninguna de
las anteriores y veamos esta 14 jugos
más 7 barras se parece la primera
expresión cierto
donovan no va a tomar 14 jugos y
comerciante barras esto también
corresponde a ninguna de las anteriores
comprobamos la respuesta perfecta